So back in February,
I received the following letter from a
student at Linfield college and
according to its website
with campuses in Mcminnville,
Portland and a prestigious online
program.
Linfield college is a premier choice in
the Pacific northwest for a high quality
traditional liberal arts education.
Want to learn more,
contact us for details about her degree
and certificate program offerings.
A student there who I won't name,
um,
sent me the followup letter.
Dear Dr. Peterson,
I'm an undergraduate student at Linfield
college in Mcminnville,
Oregon.
The international students for Liberty
Conference recently granted me a small
sum to organize pro liberty events on
campus with an emphasis on the
importance of free speech.
I'm writing to ask you if you're
accepting speaking invitations at this
time and if your schedule sometime
between now and may would allow it to
help narrow down my options.
I would like to offer you $1,500 and an
invitation to speak here this spring
semester.
Your travel and accommodation costs will
also be covered.
I perceived Linfield as an institution
at an ideological crossroads.
I feel it is my responsibility to pick
the most effective voice possible for
helping lynnfield chart a course that
will ensure its future as a place of
reason and academic integrity.
After listening to many of your lectures
and interviews,
I believe your message is ideal for our
campus.
Honest and productive argumentation is
one of your specialties.
Lynnfield would greatly benefit from
being introduced to your ideas on the
subject.
We are a small college of roughly 2000
students situated in quiet wine country.
Your work continues to have a deep
impact on my personal and intellectual
growth.
I'd be honored to hear from you.
Thank you for your time and
consideration.
So after considering it for awhile,
I agreed to come and speak at Linfield
College.
On March 18th I received a note from an
invitation student,
the inviting student who said,
good morning Dr. Peterson.
I would be overjoyed to confirm a date.
So we went about doing that.
On April 7th he replied to me again to
update me.
He said,
the talk will be held in Ice Auditorium
in Melrose Hall.
April 24th beginning at 7:00 PM I'm
referring to the event simply as a talk
with Jordan Peterson because his
speaking style allows for a lot of
fluidity in topic.
However,
the core theme to the event is the
importance of freedom of speech,
especially in higher education.
Some of the administration slash student
government have began to fret about the
potential for people to feel open,
quote,
offended and oppressed.
Closed quote by Peter since talk.
It's more pushback than I expected at
Linfield,
but I don't think it's a cause for
concern.
I'm fighting hard to keep their worries
at bay and there's a very supportive
group of students and community members
who have my back free speech.
We'll win.
On April 17th the following article
appeared in the student newspaper,
Bye Kelly or Neil,
editor in chief.
It's called hate symbol on ball riles
campus.
The Lindsay of young Americans for
liberty groups,
free speech ball outside of Walker Hall
on April 12th received attention from
students and faculty when a student drew
pepe the frog,
which has recently been appropriated by
white supremacist groups.
Linfield college posted a picture of the
ball on it's an instagram account,
but it was later removed because of the
frogs association with alt right groups.
As soon as it was pointed out that the
photo included the image,
the instagram post was removed,
President Thomas helped set the free
speech ball event.
The first event in the speak freely at
series at linfield encourage students to
express themselves by writing and
drawing on the ball to promote free
speech.
Pepe the frog is a popular Internet mean
that is often appeared in humorous ways.
The Anti Defamation League has listed
pepe the frog on it to heat symbols
database.
I only heard about it second hand and I
understand that it is a place for free
speech,
but in all reality it was certainly done
in very poor taste.
Junior John Christianson set according
to its website,
the y a l mission is to open quote,
identify,
educate,
train,
and mobilize youth activists committed
to winning on principle.
Our goal is to cast the leaders of
tomorrow and reclaim the policies,
candidates,
and direction of our government.
Close quote,
a member of y,
a l drew.
The pepe the frog on the ball,
but asked to remain unidentified open
court.
I knew the person who drew peppy.
He didn't draw it to be negative.
He drew it to be funny.
Close quote,
senior Parker Wells,
a member of y a l said he continued.
We understand some groups appropriated
the image,
but any image can be appropriated.
Well said his goals with the free speech
ball.
We're to get people thinking about the
rights to free expression and to bring
more attention to the y a l group.
He said,
I understand that it's necessary to set
limits,
but I don't think this cartoon fraud is
a limit to set for free speech.
I find it unfortunate that people can't
enjoy this event because of the frog
image
as a part of it.
Speak freely.
Series y a l is bringing Dr. Jordan
Peterson to campus on Monday,
April 24th the group is also showing the
documentary the red pill on Tuesday,
May 2nd
professor of English Rashmi.
Dot.
Valor stats set open quotes.
All right,
fine.
Both the invitation of Jordan Peterson
and the screening of the documentary,
the red by the young Americans for
Liberty Club.
Extremely problematic.
Problematic because neither peterson
northern film,
we'll be promoting dialogues about
gendered inclusions,
but rather be promoting a dangerous and
offensive logic of gendered exclusions.
Dr. Butler staff continued the promotion
of such exclusionary practices,
greatly threatened safe spaces for our
students,
staff and faculty who belonged to
marginalized groups and violates our
ethos of upholding mutual respect on our
campus.
The president's diversity committee,
we're holding discussion at 5:30 PM on
Monday in the pioneer reading room
titled Free Speech,
what it is and what it is,
not the discussion.
We'll examine free speech and members of
the Linfield community are encouraged to
attend.
So that's the end of that newspaper
article.
So I read that it was forwarded to me
soon after I tweeted the following
message.
Open quote,
I'm violating some more safe spaces.
Suit Linfield College.
April 24th
well on April 19th I received a letter
from the student who would organize my
talk.
He said,
things have gone nuclear.
This email.
The one I'm going to read to you was
just sad to all of Lynnfield.
One of the stipulations they are
referring to is the contract which they
rejected because it was a day late.
Our Club is currently looking for space
in downtown in Mcminnville to hold
Peterson's talk in step.
The media is likely getting involved.
I'm sorry for this insanity.
We tried very hard to keep things civil
here,
so here is the letter sent out to the
entire community
Lynnfield community.
I am writing on behalf of the Linfield
cabinet as officer in charge,
what President Peli is out.
I want to let the Linfield community
know that the a s l c associated
students of Linfield college has
determined it will not fund Dr. Jordan
Peterson appearance next week because
stipulations for the event were not met
by the requester,
young Americans for liberty.
Since the authorization parameters,
we're not satisfied.
The college will not host the event on
April 24th among the stipulations was
that the event was to be a private
linfield college only event by his own
tweet yesterday to 107,000 followers.
Dr. Peterson indicates he would be open
quote,
violating more safe spaces.
Sued Linfield College,
close quote,
likeminded supporters from outside our
community have responded affirmatively.
Our policy on anti harassment protection
and academic freedom states that open
quote,
Andy harassment policies are not
intended to limit the free exchange of
opinions or the vigorous debate over
ideas.
However,
intimidation,
harassment,
exploitation,
and the use or threat of force are
incompatible with the preservation of
this freedom.
The letter continues based on the
speaker's own words.
This event no longer presents the
possibility of academic inquiry within
the Linfield community.
Our policy is clear,
open quote,
harassment and intimidation preclude the
very possibility for maintaining an
atmosphere of academic freedom.
We cannot welcome speakers when the
stipulations for their appearances are
not met and who attend,
who intend to violate the safety of our
community.
Respectfully,
Susan Egg Ref Kip in hand.
So I wrote a letter to Susan Agra,
Kevin Hamm.
Now you understand that by this time the
flights had been arranged,
the accommodation had been arranged,
everything was in place,
and of course they had known about this
for a long time.
Dear Susan,
I received a copy of your letter to the
Linfield community this morning as well
as an indication that my long scheduled
talk at Linfield has been canceled.
That is fine,
I suppose except that the plane tickets
have been booked and the hotel
reservations have been made as well as
three days taken out of my schedule at
my expense.
I think you are treating me and the
student group who invited me in a manner
that is absolutely reprehensible as well
as cowardly,
an underhanded.
I have made arrangements to come to
linfield which is extremely distant from
me and out of the way in good faith.
Now you cancel it with a plethora of
specious reasons including your anti
harassment policy.
Although I have harassed no one nor
intimidated,
exploited,
or threaten force had I not previously
received notice of the controversy
around my arrival,
which is in my opinion on warranted,
I would not have tweeted my intent to
open quote,
violate safe spaces,
close quote,
which is a satirical comment in case it
needs to be said.
Obviously you were looking for any
excuse no matter how trivial to cancel
this event.
You also note that open quote,
this event no longer presents the
possibility of academic inquiry within
the Linfield community close quote,
I might point out that Linfield,
it's a college,
not a community and that ideas need to
be discussed in a college.
You also state that open quote,
anti harassment policies are not
intended to limit the free exchange of
opinions or the vigorous debate over
ideas,
close quote and then proceed to do
exactly that.
You also mentioned that you have
received support from open quote like
binded supporters,
close quote from outside your community,
which is hardly surprising or
informative given that they were
likeminded.
You also suggest that because the
contract was delayed one day,
that constitutes sufficient grounds for
cancellation even though you knew well
that the event was booked and finalized
and it's such delays are by no means
unheard of in such situations.
You might also note that aghast invited
to your college might expect to be
treated with a modicum of consideration
and respect.
Here's what I plan to do.
I'm going to make a video tomorrow
morning at the latest reading this
letter on Youtube,
explaining that by invitation has been
revoked.
What that means for me and the nature of
the reasons given.
I will also read this letter of response
from me.
It should be watched by about 150,000
viewers,
many of whom I imagine we'll be
lynnfield alumni supporters and
students.
I'm perfectly willing to see what they
all have to say.
Then we can let the dust settle where it
may sincerely,
Dr. Jordan B.
Peterson,
professor of psychology at University of
Toronto.
I received absolutely nothing in
response.
I've got no,
uh,
he didn't even have the decency to send
me a notification explaining their
rationale.
Nothing.
So I was treated as far as I'm concerned
with,
with uh,
well let's call it unprofessionally and
leave it at that.
So what's the story now?
The organizing students tried to book an
alternative venue.
They didn't have enough money to rent a
suitable theater or lecture hall.
I told them that they could use my
honorarium to pay for the space,
which they did.
The yamhill valley news.
register.com posted this update April
20th off campus venue found for
controversial speaker.
Linfield college is student government
organization this week with drew
permission for a newly organized club,
young Americans for liberty to bring a
controversial speaker to campus for a
free public talk.
Monday,
the group has responded by lining up an
off campus location for the presentation
featuring Jordan Peterson,
I Canadian professor whose campaign
against gender neutral pronouns is
considered offensive by some do the
transgender population.
Peterson has been rebooked for seven to
9:00 PM at the falls event center housed
in the former chapel on the evergreen
aviation and space museum campus.
So on with the show,
and you can figure out what I think of
the linfield administrators who pulled
this stunt on your own.
Thanks for watching.